welcome to CBS this morning and we begin
in Washington where President Trump and
his allies are celebrating the end of
his impeachment trial and slamming the
one Republican who voted to remove him
from office it is a story leading
headlines across the country today more
than half the Senate rejected both
articles of impeachment abuse of power
and obstruction of Congress the Joe the
vote was along party lines except for a
single guilty vote from Utah senator
Mitt Romney on the first count abuse of
power during an emotional speech the
senator said he was following his
conscience it's the first time a senator
has voted to remove a president of his
own party in response mr. Trump called
Romney a failed presidential candidate
Nancy Cordes on Capitol Hill covered the
entire impeachment saga and Nancy what's
next well what's next Anthony is that we
hear from the President himself at noon
Eastern Time
his aides say that he is pleased but not
surprised here on Capitol Hill it has
been a bruising ordeal and one senator
described it as the most difficult
decision he has ever had to make
it's over America the White House
celebrated Wednesday night
president Trump declaring it our
country's victory after a nearly five
month long process with more than 30
hours of public witness testimony and
180 questions from senators the vote as
expected fell well short of the
two-thirds needed for removals that the
said Donald John Trump be and he is
hereby acquitted of the charges and said
articles it was in the end a straight
party-line vote with one notable
exception the president is guilty of an
appalling abuse of public trust Utah
Republican Mitt Romney said the
President did commit a high crime or
misdemeanor when he used military aid to
pressure Ukraine to investigate a
political rival and his son there's no
question in my mind that were their
names not Biden the president would
never have done what he did he made his
decision as I said I think it's a
mistake Senate Republicans were
forgiving Mitt Romney
had us fool president was less so
tweeting out this video claiming Romney
is a Democrat secret asset after the
vote Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
repeatedly refused to say as he has for
months whether mr. Trump did anything
wrong as far as I'm concerned it's in
the rearview mirror what I'm here to
talk about today is the political impact
President Clinton apologized after his
impeachment acquittal in 1999 I want to
say again to the American people how
profoundly sorry I am for what I said
and did to trigger these events
Democrats do not expect the same
contrition from mr. Trump I would pray
to the good Lord you know I didn't see
that lesson them the Senate is now
adjourned until Monday when it takes up
a judicial nomination a sign that this
body is getting back to business as
usual and working on the president's top
priorities Anthony
Nancy thank you